hello I'm Gavin I'm Dan we're the slow
mo guys and for this video we've
partnered with Oreo Dan it's been said
that some people will do anything for an
Oreo I do like an Oreo can't go wrong
with an Oreo true so they got in touch
and they asked me to come up with an
anything and this is our anything yeah I
had wondered why we're on this massive
platform for the giant ball of milk does
that make me the Oreo in this situation
no no you're not an Oreo okay your door
here is the price okay this is the
treadmill waiter the question we're
going to answer Dan is would you dresses
aware hold a tray full of milk yes yes
and run on a treadmill for an Oreo I
know if I don't keep up I'm just gonna
end up eating yeah as long as they get
like more than one Oreo or maple walk
out like a scoring system rotation you
know air distance okay I'll give it good
we'll give it a go and we'll capture it
in glorious 4k slow motion ice down
tumble through the air into a milk oh
this fancies a fancy establishment I
even get a bowtie look at that
all right so pop around there and get
that one all right just so you know this
isn't real milk we didn't really want to
waste that much so just cornstarch in
war
you look the part
uh yeah I think so I mean what kind of
restaurant though serves serves drinks
in a plastic cup but you have to wear I
won't a bowtie as a way for more like
which restaurant serves milk which table
nine right some milk it's that's more
down to the person ordering milk right
okay so start slow we'll start one mile
an hour I'm gonna be triggering the
camera here and we've also got this
little lovely lad who's gonna film your
impact on the treadmill this is already
difficult it's not a good sign
feeling good about it I think so we'll
start up in a speed where it one or half
I'm nervous I'm like quavering slightly
I've never been this nervous delivering
milk before think about the Oreos dad
think about the Oreos okay okay
turn off okay this is a rapid milk
delivery yeah you know what there's a
but that just says ten I think we'll
just go on ten okay
oh he's doing well can't just be on the
treadmill there we go thirty-six there's
only six this is ten sounds like a plane
- you're right dad you almost made it to
top speed so what how do you feel do you
feel like on their shoe oh I'm sorry
all right there so I did it early
triggered because I know it's that when
the milk went it was all over from there
yeah we started to concentrate on what I
was doing I'm really running here
actually you got booked in it
look this is one of the weirdest things
we remember Phil look at this this is my
society this is all right that guy's the
first milk oh it's all over that's the
tray off balance
Oh God
my lady just gone completely Superman
dip your midair falling belly flopping
towards a moving floor Oh God
you can seal the milk shooting at the
end of it Oh foot skim the surface and
didn't touch your like treading milk for
a second line without touching it
there's the waiter the tree coming down
after me that's the tray yeah
oh I did a full 180 like I was on my
front and then the things shot me
outwards and I was on my back well let's
let's analyze it so you lost all three
milks so that's minus three but I feel
like your impact score yeah we'll give
you two for the air I tried to like hold
on there but I couldn't because I was
like I was like I'm losing my balance
that's two points the rotation 180
degrees that's 180 so I think that's 183
points so how many Oreos 183 points well
do the calculation that's four Oreos now
it's four and a half for a half or yes
that's very good
okay let's try let's try and beat the
score all right I'm really nervous again
table tens are some milk they came in
they handed out hundreds of free Oreos
never needs the milk well how come
there's a free and I have to do this to
mine oh good
oh man you're not messing about so uh Oh
what's your favorite color
Oh
oh I got some in my mouth
actually maybe with something down here
you just did a sea of milk if we score
this one that is a ten points for the
head bar okay four points on impact
and the rotation not as much maybe 60
points okay so that's 12 Oreos
well I got 180 points last time and I
got four and a half for erosion rates
algebra okay yeah yeah sure
all right then for this one the camera
is very wide very low down so the height
of the splash will be the focus of this
one
okay let's start you up you getting
better at it
he's rocking it he's rocking max
look at look at this speed oh I took
some of the treadmill with me that time
that was an absolutely back slam Oh
how'd you do that
I have no idea I actually don't know
well let's analyze the footage
oh I've properly lost it there
[Laughter]
[Music]
the face is coveted
dan that was amazing
well not good none of the people got
their milk well no one got any milk but
you excellent bounce excellent rotation
yeah splash height well it was quite
good at the end yeah commendable well
worth it for the Oreo so I'm gonna go
win do you want about 17 Oreo I had 16
and a half after the first to go
yeah the last one was just a half Oreo
but thank you
only 14 minutes I'll owe you one
well thank you very much for watching
that video I enjoyed that hopefully you
did - feel free to subscribe to the slow
mo guys and a big old thanks to Oreo why
are you in when you do anything all
right
what
what about the letter